hello everyone my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara's never seen
and tonight I am watching the Muppets
Christmas Carol yes I know I look like
everyone's grandma but I'm really
Michael kind I've seen a ton of
renditions of Christmas Carol I've been
in Christmas Carol the musical version
stage adaptation I've only seen one of
the Muppet movies which is the Muppet
movie I have extremely high hopes for
this where I didn't for the last two
holiday films I saw were Tim Allen Santa
Claus and eight crazy nights which to be
fair I came out of those actually
enjoying them still so this one I really
think I'm going to enjoy Michael I think
Michael Caine as Scrooge is going to be
lovely beautiful just magnificent so - I
have to say Mort no okay let's do it
[Music]
the tree topper not a head what is a bad
Muppets movie because I've seen two and
both of them were 10 out of 10 fantastic
just exactly what the doctor ordered if
he ordered movies I don't know guys with
this made in 1993
it feels so relevant now so not dated
whereas the other early 2000s early 90s
Christmas holiday films that I've seen
already for tamers never seen holiday
extravaganza which that's not a thing
but it should be December is now called
Tamra's never seen holiday extravaganza
I never could remember the other two
that I've seen have felt extremely
lovably and not so lovably dated I know
this The Muppets are just timeless and
wonderful and beloved but I don't know
are there bad movies that aren't
wonderful love it and beloved not
talking about happy time murders here
I'm pretty sure Rob Walker hasn't seen
which one is it Muppet Treasure Island
he's not seeing one of them we're gonna
watch that I'm so pumped on the
muffins terrible sentence I'll never say
it again hello and welcome to The
Muppets Christmas special I'm here to
tell the story and I'm here for the food
that's literally like Doug and me every
time I show up to fill the nostalgia
critic be a very good snacks the ebony
Czar song is very lame Izzy somehow and
I love it the music is legit good it's
actually so enjoyable verses eight crazy
nights where I enjoyed one of the songs
one of them just one I don't know why
I'm comparing this to a crazy nights and
also this Santa Claus so much but I
think it's because I just recently
watched them all together but you love
how my
go kinda high news when I scrapped my
egg Wow it's a really good mic okay in
Tamara thank you a now speaking of my
next notice
oh holy young Michael Caine Batman this
is just adorable I'm so happy I feel so
Christmassy and all is right in the
world thank you Michael
I don't know how many more times I'm
gonna say Michael kind in this review
but at least a hundred so yeah it's kind
of hard for me to do an episode of this
other than just saying it's good thank
you
the Christmas theme because everyone
knows the story of Scrooge so I can't
let go beat by beat kind of what happens
nothing really sticks out in the story
the characters do and the writing does
but I mean you know even the writing
it's not it's all it's all it's the
characters you know it's the writing you
know it's the story you know it's all
the Charles Dickens classic A Christmas
Carol so there's not much to say on that
end it's just all really in the details
of the characters and how they tell it
and how they sing it and how they
express it in the puppetry Oh up a tree
I've been watching a lot of Netflix
Christmas specials recently because
they're fun as hell listen mmm
masterful
damn but this comparatively is so much
better not that those aren't amazing
they're a different kind of amazing a
lesser amazing you know that being said
though it is still a great twist on it
it's not exactly verbatim the story that
we know and love like the first ghost
ghosts show up and it's Jacob and Robert
Marley
it's the critics and it's really great
it's super fun
they are Christmas past and they sing
this amazing song and it goes something
like freedom comes with giving love and
prison comes with hate that is real
it got me the heart
I love the lessons that the Muppets
teach oh my gosh I'm saying something
that literally everyone agrees with and
already knows and I'm just having this
realization now it's nothing I'm not
there's no I'm not bringing anything to
the table with this reaction I'm just
like ah
also the narrators are really great it
could have easily just been the
character straight up and not have a
narrator or two narrators and the
narrators are perfect gonzo and rizz
the adorable mouths I want to rat so bad
you guys every time I see a rat as a
character only another note about rats
the mice are so cute give them to me
Christmas present arrives jolly huge
great red beard who doesn't love a red
beard colorblind people just thought
okay ghost of future comes which is you
know scary and amazing I kind of cast
them out past would be Doug Walker
Christmas present with the Rob Walker as
Santa Christ and Christmas future would
be Malcolm s the devil and then probably
hyper fangirl would be the nephew the
excited nephew and all the rats and mice
probably then the ghost of future shows
the Tiny Tim part I cried at the Tiny
Tim part which is a scene i've seen
played out at least ten times in my life
at least like at least ten times in my
life of 27 years I've seen and I cried
at it that's not good right yeah I know
there's a great quote in the movie these
events can be changed a life can be made
right from the ghost of the present and
I just wrote you should comment that on
all troll persons these events can be
changed your life can be made right stop
being a dick and then Michael kind sings
and I just wrote Walter in parentheses I
had more time for this this was gonna be
a whole to do well my good heavenly
Christmas God that was so sweet
the original songs were amazing the
puppetry obviously really really great
the sets were really cool I loved the
twist on it I thought it was just super
wholesome super sweet super Christmas
classic that I have somehow missed
slipped completely under my radar all
Muppet movies have slipped completely
under my radar I don't know how I missed
them all but they're all really great
and really
a total total watch every year like a
watch every year film hmm I hope
everyone has a lovely christmas hanukkah
kwanzaa
holiday season anything you celebrate or
don't celebrate I hope that it's filled
with love and surrounded by people that
love you and you love back and delicious
food and your happiness enjoyment and I
appreciate guys for watching thank you
so much I'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you